not a great deal day weather-wise but
here's a good day for why my career is
quite it's really good to have the
beginning of a cycle way between
carpooling run yura and this will add to
our soccerway network around the
district and it's of course linking at
humane towns so that's fantastic towns
like bring your ax and cowboy now are
part of Greater Christchurch
so this cycle way will link to the cycle
ways going into Christchurch City and it
also is about providing safe places to
cycle because of course the cycle way
will be separated for the road and that
can give people some security and
certainty and getting out on their bikes
in in cycling in a safe environment
19:17 was the year of the Battle of
Passchendaele were a huge number of New
Zealanders including people from this
district lost their lives and and it
seemed very appropriate to name this
cycle way after that very tragic day of
New Zealand history a lot of New
Zealanders or still in passion there in
the ground and so this is very
significant for us also to have
something here that linked us together